doing a comedy club in grand rapids
michigan and uh i do a show and you know
standing ovation has a everything sure
yeah yeah and so i'm out celebrating
afterwards and i have a couple of beers
you know by a couple i mean like how
many yeah 16 17. and uh
and also a shot some shots they kept
sending me that's lethal i go back to
the hotel uh and i'm there and uh and
i'm doing the aspirin water trick you're
familiar with that yeah uh if you they
say if you drink a lot of water right
and you have some aspirin uh that you
will not have a hangover don't have a
hangover i think it was copperfield that
came up with that trick david
copperfield yeah right through that and
he made the empire state building
disappeared those were stupid ones yeah
that makes the empire state building and
hangovers disappear just gone so
uh i'm i i take the aspirin i take the
water uh i'm following the instructions
the great illusionist taught us and um
i head over to the sink uh to brush my
teeth right clean it up right even
hammered i gotta i gotta take care of
these choppers yeah so i'm at the sink
and
no one says take care of these stoppers
no one before they brush their teeth
says time to take care of these choppers
that's where you're wrong i think
there's a camera on me at all times and
i do a tape to the camera
time to clean the choppers yeah well
i wouldn't know what that's like uh
that's my whole life go ahead go ahead
so i'm at the sink and uh i'm i'm
attempting to put paste on brush and um
the sink set up by the way didn't have
the knobs right he didn't have the knobs
for the water it had that one big metal
one you know what i'm talking about yes
like a throttle it's like a throttle or
like a giant switchblade just begging
for you to pummel your eyeball into
right so i'm there and i'm
and uh i don't know what came over me
i'm i'm gonna guess this aforementioned
alcohol but i swear to god if that thing
had a magnet on it i wouldn't have sewed
that on
i'm there and i'm like oh you can't be
bam
i smashed my head on it so hard when i
pulled it off a pop noise happened right
blood is spurting everywhere i'm writing
red rum in the mirror just to stay awake
right right right i passed out for about
two hours in a pool of my own blood i
come to i lost i don't know conan i'm
not a doctor
29 gallons that's not accurate
yeah the human body holds 40. so yeah oh
so i lost you so oh good i still had 11.
yeah so
i'm uh i i come to i'm not in great
shape i've got to catch a flight in like
two hours and uh i don't have any
band-aids this is still gushing like a
geyser families are lining up with the
cameras and um
i uh i don't have any band-aids because
this wasn't planned on happening so i've
got to rip a pillow case up and tie it
around my head to stop the bleeding torn
pillowcase around your head with a
launch a massive head wound right
yes so i i'm walking down the hallway
with that around my head with a little
blood i'm playing a fight like i'm in
the third of seven
so i get down to the front desk
and i'm i'm woozy i'm woozy do you
understand what i'm saying here it's
woozy what you're saying woozy
woozy i'm saying woozy that doesn't
sound that way to me
my show uh
don't
[Applause]
you've got to get that word right it's
my show right i got the right word yeah
yeah yeah exactly oh please his name's
on the program relax i uh
i go down to the front desk the woman
behind the counter sees it uh wants to
comment on it but doesn't want to
because maybe that's always my forehead
you know what i mean right
you can't say hey what's with your
forehead right now it's a birthmark
she's like oh damn it foot and mouth
yeah so instead she pretends that she's
not looking at it so she's like checking
me out okay mr pearl let's take a look
here and take a look
let's see that there he goes like she's
got the she's looking out but the lizard
eyes over here taking a peeky boo yeah
i'm about to pass out again so i say to
her uh hey do you think this needs
medical attention
and as if she's been waiting her entire
life to answer this question oh my god
yes
[Laughter]
so loud housekeeping comes running down
the hall they see it what are they doing
grand rapids spray lysol on it no they
did real life even hammered that stings
a little bit baby yeah
i had to go to the doctor he got 49
stitches and uh two two stitches okay
and um
yeah 49 is if they removed your brain
yeah
they may have done that
uh
so so that's when you decided i'm done
with the boost i said enough's enough uh
and uh and i cleaned up the system like
now i treat my body like a temple you
know that you see me at the gymnasium on
a daily basis never seen you there uh
not once not once
not one